يتواصل استهداف طائرات الجيش السوداني
لمناطق تمركز قوات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم وتحديدا محيط القصر والقياده
العامه فيما تصدت لها المضادات الارضيه
التابعه لقوات الدعم السريع الجيش
السوداني يقول انه دمر تقريبا نصف القدرات
القتاليه للدعم السريع وان الوضع في مختلف
الولايات مطمئن عدا الخرطوم التي ما زالت
تشهد الاشتباكات الدعم السريع من جهته
يؤكد انه سيطر على معظم المناطق العاصمه
الخرطوم بينما ينفي الجيش الامر مؤكدا حسم
القتال لصالحه في الخرطوم قريبا للغايه
فيما يتهم الجيش الدعم السريع باتخاذ
المواطنين دروعا بشريه وذلك بالانتشار وسط
المناطق السكنيه بينما يوجه الدعم السريع
اتهامات للجيش بانه يقصف المدنيين كلا
الطرفين يؤكد حسمه قريبا للمعركه لكن
الواقع على الارض يظهر انه لا امد قريب
لانتهاء القتال والذي دخل حتى الان اسبوعه
الثالث وادى لمقت ل واصابه المياه ونزوحها
عشرات الالاف لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات